("Over the Divide" by
Warner/Chappell Production music)
- I can't say I felt
represented growing up.
- I think the only Latin character
that there is in the Disney universe
is a Chihuahua.
- I think the Princess and the Frog.
I was kinda older so I wasn't
really able get into it.
- I have faith that Disney's
gonna get there one day.
And I know that.
You know, if you need
a Korean male character
to base anything on, I'm
totally a cartoon already.
("Over the Divide")
- So we make you a Korean prince then?
- That would be excellent.
So I'm on this mission to
destroy this Fox princess.
This priestess.
- Yes
- And I'm accompanied by my dog.
- So my prince is a Merman.
I want to say he falls in love with
a guy who sings with his guitarra.
- I feel like if Maya
Angelou and Fran Lebowitz
had a baby, that would be me.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Should
I put earrings on you?
- Sometimes. I wear them from Claire's.
(laughs)
- Regal.
A lot of swag.
Swords.
- Swords, huh?
- Sword and black power.
- [Voiceover] Yep, there you are.
- He's way cooler than me.
("Over the Divide")
- Do I close my eyes?
- [Voiceover] Cover your eyes.
- [Guy in black shirt] All right.
- [Voiceover] Open!
- [Guy with blue shirt] I'm scared.
- (screams) I'm like, I'm too excited.
Okay, should I? Okay.
Oh my god! (laughs)
Oh my god!
- Oh my god, I love it!
That is so cool!
- Holy (bleep). That's (bleep) dope.
- Oh, hell yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- I never really thought
about how much I looked
like a Spanish (foreign language)
and there's a little heart on my face.
Aww, that's perfect.
Hearts are actually my symbol
that I put on everything.
- Definitely want to see that as a movie.
I gotta picture it now, I got to write it.
I think for me, when I
started growing my hair out,
it meant a lot.
'Cause it was like, "oh, this
is completely different."
I get different reactions from people,
and I kind of felt like a strength in it.
- Dang!
And my eyebrows on fleek, too.
- I really love the hat.
I love the details of the clothes,
and I'm really just
digging my dog companion
who also has a sword.
- I am the first gay,
Cuban Merman of Disney.
- Thanks, John, this is amazing!
This looks so good.
- Not only could Korean
kids respond to this,
but I think a lot of kids in
general would respond to this.
You could really base
an animated film off of
on anyone's story or anyone's dream,
and it could come out into
something awesome and marketable.
And I think this looks like both.
("Over the Divide")
(woosh)
(squeaky)